en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos
iniciamos en el espacio porque china
lanzó la misión junio 14 con tres
taikonautas a bordo estarán seis meses
en la estación espacial tiangong y su
misión es finalizar la construcción de
esta instalación así hablaban los
taikonautas antes de salir de la tierra
unión experimentaremos nueve
configuraciones complejas en la estación
espacial y vamos a conducir pruebas y
acoplamientos también realizaremos tres
simulacros de salida dos experimentos de
transposición y pruebas en brazos
mecánicos los tres somos un respaldo el
uno para el otro en términos de
asignaciones de misión y habilidades
social
se espera que durante su estancia dos
módulos laboratorio y uno de carga sean
enviados al espacio por lo que serán
ellos los responsables de que todas
estas partes de la estación tiangong
queden operativas
la misión senior 14 es mucho más
complicada por lo que nos preparamos
durante dos años y medio el módulo
laboratorio went jan tendrá tres zonas
de dormir y un área sanitaria y el
sistema de control de ambiente y soporte
vital necesita una copia de seguridad
además utilizaremos la cabina de la
exclusa de aire del white and para
llevar a cabo actividades
extravehiculares
los taikonautas realizarán numerosos
experimentos científicos sobre ciencia
espacial medicina y sistemas
aeronáuticos los expertos que hacen
parte de la misión en la tierra además
informaron de 24 pruebas médicas que ya
iniciará
podemos dividir los 24 experimentos en
tres categorías la primera es comprender
mejor el entorno de ingravidez y el
impacto de los vuelos espaciales en los
humanos en términos fisiológicos la
segunda es ver los efectos de los vuelos
espaciales en las capacidades humanas y
estudiar las características de los
cambios en las habilidades de las
personas
desde el enfoque de la teoría del
mecanismo comprender mejor la razón por
la cual el mecanismo cambia en el
entorno espacial tanto de chinches se
llama los taikonautas de la misión 14
estarán en el espacio para recibir a sus
sucesores de la misión 15 con quienes se
prevé que coincidan durante
aproximadamente una semana será entonces
un récord de convivencia de 6
taikonautas en misiones tripuladas
chinas
vamos ahora hasta la unión europea
porque el bloque llegó a un acuerdo
sobre un único cargador dentro del
territorio comunitario se trata del tipo
usb ce en principio puede que la idea no
genere entusiasmo sin embargo se trata
de una medida cuyo objetivo es que los
consumidores puedan comprar nuevos
dispositivos electrónicos sin tener que
adquirir cargadores adicionales
con los consumidores europeos estaban
frustrados con los múltiples cargadores
acumulándose en sus hogares
sting el charter ahora podrán usar un
solo cargador para todos los aparatos
portátiles lo que es un paso importante
en beneficio de los consumidores y para
reducir los desperdicios hueso tal como
lo decía el eurodiputado puede que no
seamos conscientes de la cantidad de
desechos que se producen si cada vez que
compramos un producto también pagamos un
nuevo cargador pues según cifras de la
comisión europea la iniciativa permitirá
evitar que se produzcan toneladas de
desechos anualmente
electrónico watch pero ayer estas nuevas
reglas ahorrarán más de mil toneladas de
desechos electrónicos al año se imaginan
solo con una ley de sión sión el
liberation off también se reducirán unos
200 kilogramos de gas carbónico lo que
es equivalente a 10 millones de
teléfonos inteligentes y a 2.600
toneladas de materia primas of mayors
sólo falta la aprobación del consejo
europeo para que desde 2024 los
teléfonos móviles tabletas libros
electrónicos cámaras digitales vídeo
consolas y auriculares ya tenga que
contar con este tipo de puerto para
carga que no será requerido en
computadores portátiles relojes
inteligentes o dispositivos para medir
la actividad física por razones técnicas
vamos hasta el reino unido donde
científicos del instituto john lynch
modificaron tomates genéticamente para
obtener una mayor cantidad de vitamina d
de estos frutos
puntualmente cada tomate contiene tanta
de esta vitamina como dos huevos o una
porción de atún los responsables incluso
señalan que las hojas de la planta de
tomate que fue editada que generalmente
son desechadas pueden usarse para
suplementos o para fortificar alimentos
en la edición de genes es un conjunto de
tecnologías que van desde un simple
recorte hasta una inserción compleja de
genes del exterior y las características
que realmente entusiasman a los
científicos son cosas como la
resistencia a las enfermedades la
resistencia a las sequías esto
simplemente no se puede lograr sin estas
complejas intervenciones tecnológicas el
estudio de estos científicos señala que
una mayor exposición a la luz solar
natural aumenta los niveles de vitamina
d en la fruta madura por lo que los
investigadores defienden que la mejor
forma de cultivarla sería precisamente
en zonas donde hay mucho sol
finalizamos en japón donde fue diseñado
un robot que busca asemejarse a una
cabra y su objetivo es transportar
cargas de hasta 100 kilogramos es una
creación de la empresa kawasaki y de
acuerdo con los responsables la
intención es ayudar con la falta de mano
de obra en la sociedad japonesa se llama
vex en honor a la cabra salvaje y dice y
cuenta con dos grandes cuernos curvos
camina sobre cuatro patas para tener
mayor estabilidad en terrenos
irregulares no obstante también cuenta
con ruedas para moverse más velozmente
en superficies lisas
así llegamos al final de esta crónica
les agradecemos su sintonía y los
invitamos a continuar con nosotros en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]